your time will come diana
you'll become all that you dream of
and more and everything will be different
those are cool i like those animal print
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is
going to be my full wonder woman 1984 review
and obviously they just dropped the opening scene
so i'll talk a little bit about that too the very
first movie in warner brothers plan to release all
their movies digitally on hbo max during 2021 even
though technically we're in december right now
as this movie is releasing is the first movie
that they're trying with this distribution style
so i'll also explain how that's going to work
depending on where you live in the world you'll
have a different way of watching it because hbo
max isn't available in every single country yet
if you're new to the channel we'll do an amazon
giveaway for gift cards all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your favorite
wonder woman moment from any of the movies she's
been in in the comments also talk a little bit
about her during the justice league snyder cut
2 because patty jenkins was talking about the
way they were writing the character but it should
go without saying from any of the trailer footage
you've probably seen from the justice league
snyder cut trailer wonder woman in that in her
in the wonder woman 1984 trailer footage they're
obviously two completely different movies tonally
but the really cool thing is that wonder woman's
character is actually really consistent between
both of those movies but the opening scene is just
a flashback to young wonder woman participating
in the amazons the themis girons version of the
olympic games the olympics were created by the
greeks wonder woman and the amazons come from
the greek gods of the dc universe so of course
they'd have their own version of the olympics
on themschira the whole scene is meant to be
foreshadowing for the rest of the movie set up
the ark and also set up some of the big twists
like you see the amazons fighting with all these
new techniques you see a bunch of new lasso
techniques that she winds up using later in the
film i'll talk about some of the fight scenes too
because everything in wonder woman 1984 is
dialed up to 11. the action scenes the comedy
the colors all the performances everything is off
the charts but like you see robin wright penn tell
young wonder woman greatness is not what you think
that's also a line that you probably heard in the
other trailers with adult wonder woman speaking
to cheetah and maxwell lord later in the movie
when things go completely off the rails and she
starts to go full cheetah patty jenkins said that
part of the reason for setting the movie in 1984
and not doing it in present day is because of
how crazy and over-the-top america was during
the 80s there's also a line in the movie from
maxwell lord that they put in all the trailers
where he says i've never been one for rules the
answer is always more that concept is kind of
the real villain of the film though there are
actual villains that she does have fights with
during the film like cheetah but the movie isn't
so much about how wonder woman defeats villains
running around fighting people like the justice
league snyder cut also coming to hbo max in
early 2021 making the movie more about greed
means that she can't run around killing greed
or even common people's desire for a better life
so that's also one of the big differences between
this movie and the first wonder woman movie is the
first wonder woman movie was more of a straight up
stop aries this evil god from burning humanity to
the ground by pushing them to bigger and bigger
world wars until they annihilate themselves
this time there is a macguffin but it's almost
like people's own desire is the real villain
and how do you get rid of that you can't really do
that the other clip at the end of that is more of
a general trailer with footage from all over the
movie just hyping up barbara minerva's eventual
transformation to cheetah and better looks at
some of the bigger fight scenes some of her
upgraded technique with the lasso of truth like
using it to deflect a bullet from steve trevor
and another big change is that in this movie she
doesn't really use her shield or sword at all
notice how in all the trailer footage you never
see her running around with it all over the place
when things go crazy that's part of the earlier
idea that i explained the idea that the movie
isn't about her running around defeating villains
because regular people are kind of the ones going
crazy during the film and that's mostly because of
that special black rock mcguffin so wonder woman
isn't going around punching everyone in the mall
slashing them up just because they've been driven
crazy by this black rock she spends the whole
movie trying to save everyone from themselves
even the main villains cheetah and maxwell lord so
it's all built into that idea that wonder woman is
this very hopeful aspirational character within
the dc universe very benevolent very motherly
type of figure running around trying to save
everyone and help them lead better lives you may
have heard patty jenkins talk a lot about how the
original christopher reeve superman movies inspire
the wonder woman movies especially when she was
making the first wonder woman film superman as
a character inspires people to be better so if
you've seen any of the new trailer footage the
way that they use humor with the action scenes and
the dynamic between all the different characters
the movie is exactly like that i feel like the
trailers do a really good job of portraying what
the actual movie is sometimes that's not always
the case like the trailers sell you a completely
different movie than what you wind up seeing in
theaters or in the comfort of your own home as is
the case with this movie because of the digital
release it's a lot of the energy and the tone
of the first wonder woman movie but with all the
dials turned up to 11 the drama the hans zimmer
music in the soundtrack is amazing han zimmer
could write the score to your life just walking
around buying groceries and it would sound epic
all the comedy the action scenes everything is
cranked up to maximum so if you didn't like the
first wonder woman movie or you didn't like any of
the trailers or you don't like gal gadot as wonder
woman you probably won't enjoy this film as much i
do think they did a much better job of writing the
script of the movie around gal gadot's strengths
as an actor whereas in the first movie they were
still kind of figuring that character and things
out just in general this time from the start
though they know exactly what they're playing to
and what she's all about so she comes off even
better than she did in the first movie i'm curious
to see how she feels in the justice league snyder
cut because even patty jenkins has been hyping up
the snyder cut because zack snyder was a producer
on the first wonder woman film i don't know if he
was a producer on this one but he was hyping
up wonder woman 1984 when he was talking about
justice league snyder cut stuff so it sounds
like they're still pretty close behind the scenes
you may have also heard too the justice league
snyder cut will be rated r because it's way
bloodier way stabbier and apparently according
to zack snyder this past week batman is dropping
all kinds of f-bombs you probably saw a bunch
of memes on social media the past couple of days
but chris pine is great as the newer fish out of
water version of steve trevor he is the maximum
fanny pack version of steve trevor in this movie
and chris pine performs it perfectly throughout
pedro pascal is fantastic as maxwell lord he goes
full nicolas cage in this movie and is totally on
purpose like i said everything in this movie even
the performances are dialed up to 11 on purpose
and it all kind of works with this theme around
the 80s and xs and just everything being way over
the top it's fun to watch how different he is in
this after watching his subtle performances in
the mandalorian season 2 episodes the past several
weeks all around he's amazing in all of his stuff
but it's just extra fun to see him go off the
rails not wearing a helmet 24/7. kristen wiig was
also great as cheetah and everything you've seen
from the different bits of the trailer footage is
exactly what you get with her character during
the movie you get the full range if you've seen
any of her bigger snl performances or sketches she
travels the complete spectrum of character arcs
in the movie she goes from this awkward bumbling
barbara minerva to full-blown comic book cheetah
villain with super powers having boss fights with
wonder woman and she did a great job with all of
it i hope they find a way to bring her back in
future dc movies maybe a suicide squad sequel or
wonder woman 3 somehow whenever they get around to
making that you may have also heard patty jenkins
next movie after this is actually going to be
the star wars rogue squadron movie that's right
she's going to have herself a star war but that
movie's not going to come out till christmas 2023
so we're probably not going to see wonder woman
3 for a hot minute also really big reminder there
is a post-credits scene that they're attaching
to the theatrical and the hbo max release they
didn't attach to the critics screening so i
haven't seen it yet nobody has seen it yet as
posting their reviews but just a big reminder
that there is an actual post post-credit scene
the only minor complaints that i had about the
movie were just a few times some of the jokes that
they reached for wound up feeling a little more
like superman 3. like i said a lot of the tone of
the wonder woman movies are inspired by the tone
of the christopher reeve superman movies so they
use comedy drama and action kind of in the same
way but sometimes wonder woman 1984 feels a little
bit more like superman 3 richard pryor superman so
occasionally wonder woman 1984 goes a little too
over the top but it didn't bother me that much
just because i had a pretty good sense for what
they were going for from all the trailer footage
but you can actually go see it in theaters right
now tickets are available in some countries you'll
have to check to see depending on where you live
but it's dropping on hbo max on christmas day
december 25th but then the next big movie next
big dc movie on hbo max after that will probably
be the justice league snyder cut it looks like
that's going to be a march release date either
way regardless 2021 seems like it's going to be
so much better than 2020 so once you do have a
chance to see the movie just let me know what
you think of it in the comments below whether
you saw it in a theater or you saw it on hbo max
there's a bunch of big stuff coming up this week
a bunch of star wars mandalorian finale stuff and
then obviously there's a bunch of marvel trailers
that dropped as well so i'll try to make videos
for everything make sure you have alerts enabled
for my channel so you don't miss any of that stuff
while you wait for everything click here for that
brand new star wars obi-wan kenobi teaser trailer
with hayden christensen coming back as darth vader
and click here for my new mandalorian season 2
episode 6 video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!